it is indeed the last full day before
the 2022 midterm elections and what a
day it is a truly packed program and we
are going to be talking about in
significant detail tomorrow really what
is at stake in this election but for
today we are going to contextualize it
we'll contextualize it by looking at
some of the final Democratic and
Republican rallies and some of the final
polling as well and one bit of polling
that came out over the last couple of
days that is particularly disturbing is
the degree to which this country the
United States has fallen into a
veritable Cesspool of conspiratorial
thinking when you really don't need to
find such conspiracies to understand
what it is that is going on in the
country and as is often the case
conspiracy theories have some kernel of
Truth in their origin but take people
very much in the wrong direction in
terms of their beliefs and let me make
it very concrete for you a new poll
shows that 44 percent of Voters see a
secret cabal that is controlling the
federal government
when you look at this poll of 1 000
registered voters conducted at the very
end of October you see that 44 overall
but it's not that dramatic a difference
between Republicans and Democrats
um 53 percent of Republicans 41 percent
of Independents and 37 percent of
Democrats believe the federal government
is controlled by a secret cabal
the thing about this is you don't need a
conspiracy theory about a secret cabal
we know that overwhelmingly government
and Industry and regulators and the
world of Finance are controlled
by those very corporations and the
wealthy individuals that run those
corporations that's the it's not a
secret cabal there's no secret here okay
these are the folks who have run things
overwhelmingly in the United States
for over a hundred years you could argue
you know maybe there was a brief period
in the 30s and 40s uh during FDR when
um it was really the government was kind
of governing the wealthy to certain
degree and not even really completely
the seeking The Conspiracy to control
secretly is what is disturbing in
particular here because you don't
actually need to look very hard for
who's really in charge there was I
believe it was a Princeton study and we
covered it years ago which found the
legislative desires of Corporations and
of the rich are much more likely to be
made into law than the legislative
desires of the average person
so we knew this already it's not a
secret it's out in the open and where it
gets dangerous is that you have Myriad
propaganda outlets and politicians and
others
who will take the kernel of Truth which
is there are entities and individuals
Beyond just the average people
whose desires are overwhelmingly
reflected in how the country is run
that's true
and then that's where you get into
Shadow government conspiracy theories
and we've seen every version of this
right now it's kind of hot with
Republicans and Trump has been
mentioning at rallies it's the marxists
the Socialists and the Communists he
doesn't know what any of those terms
mean doesn't know the differences
between those two those three terms but
he uses them that's who is secretly
controlling everything and then if you
think about it clearly you go and you
look and say okay if Communists are
controlling the US first thing we should
do is find Communists and then you go
and you don't find any there's no
Communists in positions of power in the
United States so you can very quickly
debunk it but that's what they're going
to and then you know the other ones
right the trilateral commission the
bilderbergs the Illuminati the Q stuff
and that theory about its pedophile it's
Democratic pedophiles who are
controlling the country it's the Jews
That's a classic as always so what's so
disturbing about some of this polling
is that
it is true
that not everyone's desires count
equally right your desires and my
desires for what we would like the law
to be don't count as much as the desires
of apple as brought to the government by
highly priced lobbyists that's true
but the secret cabal which lends itself
to all sorts of xenophobia and racism
and conspiracy theories you don't need
it it's all out in the open and of
course we know that when you believe in
the subterfuge When You Believe In The
Conspiracy Theory aspect of it
um
you often vote in ways that don't really
make any sense because you believe
things that simply are not true so
anyway that's context to some degree for
how people will be voting tomorrow
before you go if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more please make sure to
subscribe to my YouTube channel you can
click the Subscribe button below or
above or wherever it is on your screen
and if you want to support my work even
more strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
Pacman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description